hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round 10 of the 2018
bullets world championship it's again
between Magnus cross and Peter Svidler
uh a rivalry that has been going on
since forever for those of you who
haven't checked out my magnus carlsen
saga starting from the 2013 candidates
tournament all the way up until his
World Chess Championship match against
women Anand you might have noticed that
I mentioned that Coulson has a negative
score against Peter spoiler but that is
in classical time format and while this
I believe this still stands until today
Carlsen still has a negative result
against wheeler in classical time format
this is not the Blitz
but always as militant Schenkel
mentioned in the live commentary spoiler
always finds a nice ideas to use against
Coulson so as I already mentioned it is
blitz so we're not going to overanalyze
it just really it's a wonderful game
excellent play by Blackwood with black
by Peter Svidler up until one point
where he could have taken Carlsen down
but perhaps he did so feel free to check
out what happened Coulson has the white
pieces and he opens with c4 now we have
g6 g3 and now C 5 Bishop to G to Bishop
to g7 both of them feeling Cairo the
king said bishops nice to see three and
now comes Knight to c6 nice to f3 we
have d6 we have castles and a six so a
very solid structure in the center by
black we have III and now Knight G to e7
the four by Carlsen Peter castles and
now comes Luke to e1 we have looked to
be it a very useful move that removes
this Bishop from a eight so in the
future if black needs it he can always
go b6 or a six and b5
I use form of however you put it b3 and
it was a very enjoyable a Peter like who
was very excited when he saw this
position with black as he himself has
played this position in 2017 against the
Michael Adams that position was wrong
and he went nice to have five
immediately but first thriller exchanges
in the center C capture some d4 Knight
capture some d4 Knight captures he
capture some d4 and only now does he go
Knight to f5
a very nice square for the night it's
hard to imagine white will be able to
kick it away of course you could go h3g
for but that's not really doing anything
but okay Bishop to e3 by Coulson also a
possibility was Bishop to b2 kind of
complicating things but in a blitz game
where you only have three minutes plus
two seconds increment you're not gonna
go for this pawn sacrifice then 94 with
a double attack against the night and
then after if I'm defending at Bishop to
e3 you transferred the attack against
the d6 pawn but you know such things are
too complicated for blitz if you don't
know them by heart so instead of this
after Knight a5 Bishop to e3 defending
the d4 pawn but allowing Knight captures
on e3 which civil or played Knight
captures rook captures we have a six and
now comes Luke to c1 so Carson also gets
this rook out of the a1 square and also
the the C file is a very nice file for
the rook Bishop to h6 would attack
against the rooks forcing f4 cross and
does play f4 and now Bishop goes back to
g7 rook d3 now improving the pressure on
along the D file as the Queen also
occupies the D file and we have b6 Queen
to d2 and now comes Bishop to d7 by
cellular preparing b5 at some point we
have h4 by Carson preparing to bring his
game to a safer Square Queen 27 and now
comes King to h2 rook F to c8 s wheeler
mobilizes his final rook and now comes a
4 so now at some point b5 will
definitely be played as their it's
pretty much the only useful breakthrough
in the position and as black does feel
more comfortable in the position it is
definitely black we'll be making the
breakthrough Busher back to e8 and then
now comes rook to e1 cousin transverses
rook over to the e-file and b5 now and
okay a captures 8 captures and now there
is a pressure against this c4 pawn so
how do you go about this you could try
something like c5 but it doesn't work
after pawn captures pawn captures and
rook captures
you're down upon and yes you will be
able to activate some pieces with 94 but
after loop moves I said before you
create an outpost for the knight on c6
but it is a little comfort
for the lost bone so after a captures on
b5 we have nightcap for some b5 Bishop
captures pawn captures and rook captures
and now Ziggler will double up along the
B file and make this V three point a
permanent target which will be well very
hard if not impossible to defend by
Carlsen cousin goes d5 as the e pawn is
pinned the the rook will be attacking
the Queen we have E 5 and now the only
way to continue in this position by
Carla for Carlson is f5 a very nice move
where ifs wiggler decides to bust his
Kings had opened in the ship reach three
and Carson will already gained some
attack attacking resources
so after f5 we have rook C to b8
doubling up to attack the b3 pawn cross
him defense at Queen to c2 and now comes
G captures on f5 Svidler decides to do
this in order to start pushing the
central pawns and here
Bishop page 3 is not such a great idea
because it once crossed and played Queen
to c2 the Queen is no longer defending
the d5 pawn and here efore would be a
very strong move for black the rook will
be overloaded you cannot keep protecting
the b3 point and also the d5 pawn once
you move the rook as let's say you want
to protect the b3 pond and recapture Sun
d5 and the black is just crushing it so
after G captures on a5 ruk to f3 was
played and now comes f4 e 4 was the most
likely the way to go after real
characters on f5 e 3 and so on
black would still have this pressure a
longer the the B file and also already
have a past
III pawn but most likely it would be a
draw an equally game here swiller tried
a different idea after loop to f3 civil
played f4 and now comes rogue captures
on f4 as the pawn is still pinned route
capture son b3 and here cousin played
Queen to a5 a feeling of course very
comfortable there's still the spin and
with the ideas of Bishop to e4 and
capturing on h7 but this Queen f5 it was
not possible in the position here a
swivel or plate looked the b1 trying to
exchange rooks and create some pressure
against the White King but he had a much
better move so feel free to pause the
video and
try to find the most weather mist for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations as it's really not not
an easy move to find and for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations no I totally messed it
up but I'm really trying to make these
videos as quickly as possible so sorry
about that but for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
rook captures on g3 this is the most
alluring mist which could have taken
down Carson and well he almost ruined
cause internment during the candidates
in 2013 and here he well I was very
close in doing it if he had played this
now of course you cannot capture the
rook if you capture it
then he captures an f4 comes with check
and this pin is well it's pretty much
irrelevant after a queen captures you
will lose this book also with check king
h3 the rook is coming over to help out
with the attack King here Queenie to
check Bishop f3 h5 check this position
of plays that plays itself you're up a
whole rook white is getting checkmated
but silver-plated rook the b1 and okay
look after some b1 rook captures and b1
and now look to g4 pinning the bishop
and also not allowing the rook to be
captured you don't want to capture on b1
and allow this capturing of the rook on
f4 so first look the g4 now comes rook
to be to pinning the bishop sailor of
course doesn't want to allow Bishop to
e4
so first King to h3 by Carlsen now comes
85 trying something we have rook to g5
as very few seconds around the clock you
do have to play play fast and here is
filler played Queen to a7 and most
likely you should have protected the
back rank as here a swingers idea is to
bring the Queen all the way down and
then create some chances against the
white king but it is not possible here
Carlson played Bishop to e4 he humans on
with his plan but it is actually
possible to checkmate here in five so
once again feel free to pause the video
and you know just for target practice
try to find a force to checkmate in
for white once again for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show Queen ch-check King 2h7
bishop three four this is I am pretty
sure you all found the disk into h6 and
now this is the move you have to find
rook captures on h5 with check forcing
the King to capture the rope then comes
Queen a5 check King h6 and now Quinta
sorry or you could have gone the g4 but
f5 also works the King to h6 and now
Queens you five will be checkmate yeah a
very nice idea our constant first went
for Bishop to g4 going for not Queen h7
but protecting h7 with the bishop we
have Queen to g1 by cellular and now as
okay stealer is threatening checkmate
here on h2 but calls and delivers a
deadly mate in one
so Quinta CA this is now checkmate as
the bishop protects the h7 square so a
really a wonderful game and a very
instructive game by sweedler with the
black pieces up until this point but
it's a bleep game so you know can't
really blame anyone but up until that
point where were that rook captures and
g3 was not played here we're loop to be
one was played here if he just played
rook captures the game is over
what yeah and of course I forgot to
mention if you don't capture the rook if
you just play something let's say you
move this rook from from harm's way then
this row can come back to g6 and now
being up two points and this rook will
not be an excellent defender and an
excellent attacker that's it's very hard
to imagine white can survive this so
yeah rook captures and g3 definitely the
star of the show that that didn't show
up so yeah I do hope you enjoyed it as
usual you can check two of my previous
video so you're thankful for watching
and I will see you soon hopefully with
some more nice games from the 2018 world
blitz championship thank you all and
I'll see you soon